all the high inflation and rate hikes
that we've been seeing over the past
several months i'm sure you've all heard
about the threat of a recession and
looming around the corner while the
media often makes a big fuss about
recessions a recession is simply two
consecutive quarters of gdp decline in
western countries this usually means a
gdp contraction of two to three percent
and this turns into international fear
but one notable region has not only been
seeing a recession but a full-on
depression and the world has barely
noticed
macau's gdp is not down 5 10 or even 20
percent macau's gdp is down an eye
watering at 56.3
if this was the us we'd probably see
negative interest rates and 20 000
stimulus checks but china hasn't really
done anything about it in fact china has
only made things worse by cracking down
on gambling hearing this i don't think
you'd be surprised here that macaos
casinos were already bleeding hundreds
of millions per month throughout the
past two years
things have only gotten worse with the
recent surge in covert cases which has
resulted in all macau casinos shutting
down completely
and given that 80 percent of government
revenue comes from casino taxes there's
no question that the entire region is on
edge so how much longer do we have until
macau's economy becomes unsalvageable
to gauge macau's economic health we
first have to take a look into whether
macau can survive without gambling of
course they're extremely dependent on
gambling it right now but can this be
changed over the next several years well
according to many experts and casino
owners the answer is a resounding noah
professor glenn mccartney from the
university of macau for example suggests
the following given that we didn't
diversify for 20 years it isn't going to
happen tomorrow there's no quick fix
similarly a casino owner named lawrence
ho says as bad as it sounds i don't
think there's a future for just a pure
non-gaming resort in macau the truth is
gaming is really the financial engine
yes you can have these great integrated
resorts but without the gaming component
the math doesn't work obviously these
are not the most reassuring of comments
but how did things even get so bad in
the first place
well to answer this we have to take a
look at how macau became the asian las
vegas in the first place taking a look
back the history of macau's gambling
route stretched all the way back to 1557
when the portuguese took over the region
at the time the chinese called the
region omagawa which means bay of the
goddess of sailors the portuguese
adopted this name into macau and with
that they opened up the first european
colony in east asia for the first 100
years the region thrived as an
international shipping hub macaw was the
perfect intermediary between asia and
the western superpowers but all of this
would change in the early 1800s you see
after the british won the 1814 opium war
against china the british and the dutch
would take control of the trading routes
between europe and china this made macau
basically irrelevant overnight macau
still played a large role when it came
to religion housing refugees and culture
but none of these factors helped the
economy desperate for new modes of
revenue the portuguese legalized illegal
activities in the 1840s one of which was
gambling at the time gambling was
socially taboo across much of asia and
it still very much is nonetheless macau
was able to attract quite a few visitors
and by the end of the century gambling
became one of the top revenue sources
for the region but it still wasn't the
dominant source you see most of the
gambling houses that popped up
throughout the first 100 years were
pretty conservative in other words
players actually had a decent chance of
winning of course the odds were still
stacked in the casino's favor but we saw
odds of 5545 or 60 40. this was good for
gambler's wallets but it wasn't the best
from a cow's bottom line
in 1962 however all of this would change
when macau granted monopoly rights to
all forms of gambling to a man named
stanley ho stanley was a ruthless
businessman who sought insane
opportunity in macau
he didn't hesitate to bring in western
games that were far more predatory he
also invested significant amounts of
money into developing the maritime
routes between mainland asia and macau
which made the region more accessible
than ever and before you knew it macau
would become the las vegas of asia while
macau's economic problems were finally
being solved portugal soon had to deal
with the cultural revolution aka the
communist revolution of china portugal
saw loads of uprisings across makawa and
while they tried to control these using
soldiers the distance between macau and
portugal made this quite difficult soon
enough portugal would find themselves
asking for china's help in controlling
the region eventually this would result
in them turning over the entire region
to china in 1999 and that's how the
macao that we know today was created
one of the biggest economic threats for
makawa is china while china has yet to
outright ban gambling in macau it's no
secret that china is strongly against
gambling ever since the communist party
took over in 1949 gambling has been
illegal in china this includes overseas
gambling as well but in practice china
doesn't generally prosecute gambling
instead they prefer to take another
approach they try to make gambling as
inaccessible as possible for example the
process of getting a visa to macau is
extremely difficult for everyday
citizens this is one of the reasons that
macau is so lucrative only rich asians
are actually able to go there during
regular times macau attracts 22 million
gamblers per year while las vegas
attracts 25 million gamblers despite
having fewer gamblers macau averages 28
billion gambling revenue while las vegas
only averages 11.1 billion dollars
clearly china's visa policies haven't
heard macau's top line all that much but
this isn't to say that macau is free
from china's control if anything china
has been more controlling than ever as
beijing has launched a full-on gambling
crackdown for example they've been
implementing facial recognition software
in macau's atms and reducing it with raw
limits they've even been considering a
digital currency to better track money
trails to casinos but why is the ccp
doing all of this right now casinos are
already getting crushed by the pandemic
so why make it even harder for them well
the answer is that the ccp is worried
about losing control ever since the
1970s china has become more and more
capitalistic and one of the best
examples of this is the toleration of
macau but they've started to feel that
they've given companies and the business
manual way too much power and influence
and the event that made it abundantly
clear to them was jack ma's infamous
speech in late 2020 if you're not
familiar with jack ma he's the founder
of alibaba and the ant group and he used
to be the richest person in china until
he got on their bad side you see in late
2020 he gave a speech in which he
criticized the ccp
he even started the speech with the
disclaimer that he's probably wrong but
the ccp didn't care all that much about
his little disclaimer jack ma would go
missing for the next three months and
ever since then jack ma has been in the
process of handing over his entire
fortune to the ccp
in fact as i'm writing the script it was
just announced that jack maul will seek
control of the ant group to the ccp
aside from destroying jack the ccp has
decided to crack down on capitalism as a
whole which of course includes macau the
recent casino shutdowns are likely a
side effect of this the last time china
shut down casinos was at the beginning
of the pandemic in february 2020 when
furious were at all-time highs but even
then they only shut them down for 15
days this time however casinos have
already been closed for three weeks is
this a mere coincidence or is the ccp
trying to show macau who's in control
i'll let you be the judge of that
even if macau survives all these
crackdowns and shutdowns they still have
a massive timer looming over their heads
you see when china took over macau in
1999 they only agreed to give macau
autonomy for 50 years macau falls under
china's one country to assistance policy
just like hong kong the policy states
that these regions are politically part
of mainland china however they have the
freedom to operate under a different
economic system for a set period of time
these regions are supposed to use this
time to morph to china's ideals before
they unite economic systems but given
the current state of macau they haven't
really made any progress in this realm
macaw is literally almost three times as
dependent on gambling as las vegas and
this is after 23 years of morphing time
clearly macau does not have any
intention of changing but it looks like
china might have different plans
according to the initial agreement macau
will become one with china in 2049 which
means that gambling will become illegal
however the general consensus has been
that china won't actually do anything
after 2049
the reasoning is that macau is simply so
popular and profitable that it doesn't
make any sense to shut it down and ruin
the region but it looks like china is
moving to the couple macau from gambling
according to wind macau chairman alan
ziemen what beijing wants is to have a
lot more non-gaming facilities and it
seems like they're planning on
leveraging the upcoming gambling license
renewal at the end of this year as a
negotiating chip honestly there's no way
these licenses don't get renewed but it
looks like the ccp wants certain
policies in place in return first the
ccp wants macau to create a special
non-gaming zone this zone will be
dedicated to tech manufacturing it
tourism medicine conventions and sports
secondly the ccp won shorter gambling
licenses right now licenses last 20
years and renewals have to be made every
five years after that moving forward
however the ccp wants 10-year licenses
followed by three year renewal periods
china also wants reform regarding
high-risk gambling for example they want
to reduce the number of slot machines
each casino can own
all these reforms are designed to move
macaw away from gambling but by the
looks of the macau economy right now
things aren't progressing all that well
and that brings us to where we are today
looking forward the state of macau will
really be dependent on what casinos
decide to do how long will they be
willing to put up with chinese politics
before they decide to leave macau under
normal circumstances this would be the
last thing they'd want to do given how
profitable macau is however most casinos
are already hurting quite a bit when
resorts for example hasn't had a single
profitable quarter since the start of
the pandemic fortunately they still have
quite a bit of cash on hand but if it
does come to shutting down a casino and
scaling back macau may very well be the
victim while macau is often the most
profitable they're also the most risky
and uncertain so when you're scaling
back you probably want to stick to areas
that are more stable and reliable like
las vegas fortunately we haven't gone to
this point yet but if china continues to
let macau's economy get destroyed this
may very well become a possibility and
if casinos start leaving macau it won't
be long till macau goes bankrupt so it's
in their best interest to keep casinos
around and honestly it's in china's best
interest to keep macau around but who
knows their interest for controller may
be greater than their interest for
preserving macau do you guys think macau
will survive china comment that down
below
also drop a like if you hope that taiwan
survives china and of course consider
checking out our discord community to
suggest future video ideas and to
consider subscribing and see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
you